شكرا لاحمد ومشاهدينا اهلا بكم وهذه
الساعه الاخباريه من العربيه انا ميسون
اعزام احييكم ونخصص معظم هذه الساعه
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان مشاهدينا نبدا
بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها اسقطت طائره
ميغ في الخرطوم واستمرار الاشتباكات
المتقطعه في ام درمان
الصحه السودانيه تتهم الدعم السريع بتحويل
المستشفيات عسكريه وتحذر من جح المستلزمات
الطبيه في دارفور
الامم المتحده تقول انها بحاجه الى مليار
ونصف المليار لتلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه
في السودان لهذا العام
وفي هذه النشره ايضا
اوكرانيا تقول انها بدات هجومها المضاده
على روسيا في باخموت وتقر بصعوبه الوضع في
المدينه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا بالتطورات في السودان
ومع استمرار خرق الهدن المعلنه منذ بدء
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع باتت
الاوضاع الطبيه في تفاقم مستمر خرجت عشرات
المستشفيات عن الخدمه فيما باتت المخازن
الطبيه فارغه وذلك في بعض الولايات مع هذا
الوضع لم يجد السودانيون الا النزوح سبيلا
حيث قالت الامم المتحده ان حوالي نصف
مليون سوداني فرو داخليا وخارجيا وذلك منذ
منتصف ابريل الماضي ويعاني اخرون طبعا من
من قرروا البقاء من ابسط الخدمات الاساسيه
من غذاء مياه وايضا كهرباء فيما يبقى ازيز
الرصاص مسموعا وان كان بشكل متقطع
في زياده
لازم انا اشتغل
لي زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه البلد ما
امنه ما بقدر طبعا الوضع بقى صعب
تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يستغل القواد ما حبابه
والخوف ما منه فايده
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا هذا على الجانب الانساني
اما فيما يتعلق بالتطورات الميدانيه فقالت
قوات الدعم السريع في بيان لها قالت انها
اسقطت الطائره من طراز ميك تابعه للجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم ذكرت قوات الدعم
السريعه انها تصدت لغارات عده شنها الجيش
السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق سكنيه
بالخرطوم
على كل قوات الدعم السريعه ايضا مشاهدينا
تقول ونقابه اطباء السودان تتحدث عن مقتل
447 قتيلا وايضا بالنسبه للاصابات تتعدى
الفي اصابه 2255 مصاب من المدنيين طبعا
هذه الارقام هي الارقام الرسميه الان منذ
بدا الاشتباكات طبعا فيما يتعلق بالجانب
الميداني الصور اظهرت ايضا استهداف طيران
الجيش السوداني لاهداف وايضا تمركزات
تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا هو رغم الهدنه المعلنه مراسل العربيه
في السودان كان قد افاد عن سماع عدويه
اسلحه ثقيله للاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
المهندسين
حيث حلق طيران الجيش السوداني في مدن
الخرطوم الثلاث واستهدف مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريعه المراسل اكد على استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم في
منطقه كفوري بالخرطوم بحري فيما شنا طيران
الجيش السوداني قصفا جويا في ولايه شرق
النيل بحسب المراسل هذا ياتي في وقت اعلنت
فيه سلطات الطيران المدني السوداني تمديدا
اغلاق المجال الجوي باستثناء طائرات
الاجلاء وايضا المساعدات
وهذه صور تظهر استمرار الاشتباكات بمناطق
حيويه في العاصمه الخرطوم دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا وقال عضو مجلس السياده السودانيه
الفريق اول ياسر العاطفي تصريحات خاصه
للعربيه قال ان الجيش يسيطر على السودان
مشيرا على ان الدعم السريع يحتمي بوجوده
بالاحياء المدنيه المكتظه بالمدنيين وله
قناصه لحمايته متحدثا عن خطط استراتيجيه
للقضاء عليه خلال اسبوعين على حد تعبيره
وصلت المعارك لسيطره كامله على كل ربوع
السوداني
عدد جيوب قليله في ولايتين اما العاصمه
القوميه والتي تم حجز معظم قوات الخونه
والاعمال المتمردين فيها فلا زالت المعارك
جاهزه وغواتنا المسلحه متوازنه ومتماسكه
تحضر انتصارات متتاليه على العدو المتمرد
تمثل التي يحتمي قوات التمرس فهو يحتمل
بمنازل المواطنين المواطنين المدنيين وبعض
المستشفيات وبعض المدارس خاصه في الاحياء
المختصه بالمدنيين ايضا احتمائهم وفي
مناطق فيها منشات حيويه
لا تتعرض للتدمير اي اي ايضا احيانا
يتحركون من مكان لاخر في بسرعه كبيره في
طرق الطرق
اماكن التي يقضي فيها المدنيين
ومعايشهم وايضا تستخدم لاجراء البعثات
الاجنبيه
وعلى الاسلحه المنازل في الاحياء المكتظه
بالسكان ايضا يوجد قناصه لحمايتهم عشان
كده التعامل معهم يكون صعب لكن الان هيئه
قياده القوات المسلحه تضع الخطط الكفيله
بتدميرهم نهائيا
العطى اضافها ايضا للعربيه ان اي وساطه
للتفاوض مع الدعم السريع غير ناجحه وان
الجيش يريد اخضاعه لسلطه الدوله موجها
شكره للسعوديه ولمصر ودوله جنوب السودان
على جهودهم نتابع انا اشكر المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه والجمهوريه مصر
العربيه الشقيقه وجمهوريه جنوب السودان
ودولت
ومنظمه الايجاد على جهدهم في ذلك الامر
لكن لكن تاكد تمام اخي الكريم ان الوضع
الان هو وضع عمليات البحث حتى ان ارسل
عدد من الممثلين فلن تنجح اي وساطه لان
الجهد فقط لاخضاء هذا التمرد لسلطه الدوله
وكما بيان لقوات الدعم السريع قد اتهم
الجيش بالتسبب في مقتل وجرح العشرات من
المواطنين بعد قصف مستشفى شرقي النيل
بالطيران الحربي واوضحت قوات الدعم
السريعه عبر حسابها على تويتر ان القصف
بالطيران شمل مستشفى شرق النيل الى جانب
قصف عدد من المصانع بالمنطقه الصناعيه
بحري وعدد من المنشات المدنيه والطبيه
والعسكريه
وقد اظهرت الصور في مدينه ود مدني بولايه
الجزيره وسط البلاد قيامه متطوعين
بمحاولات تامين الطعام وايضا الماوى لالاف
الفرينه من الاشتباكات نتابعه
الناس لازم تهدا يشوفوا طريقه انه يحلوا
الموضوع ده لو ما قدروا يحلوا الموضوع ده
انا بتطلب من الامم المتحده تتدخل تشوف
امري لاحمتي
[موسيقى]
وفي محاوله لمواجهه حاله الانفلات
المستمره جراء الاشتباكات اعلنت الشرطه
السودانيه الدفع بتعزيزات امنيه لتامين
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه والاحياء كما
اشرت الشرطه الى قيامها بحملات خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه في عدد من مناطق
جنوب الخرطوم بمشاركه وتنسيق امني ايضا
مشترك مع القوات المسلحه
وفي تطورات عمليات الاجلاء قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها الجويه قامت
باجلاء اكثر من 200 شخص من الاراضي
السودانيه طبعا بناء على قرار الرئيس
مضيفه ان اربع طائرات عسكريه قامت بعمليات
الاجلاء حيث شملت موظفي البعثه
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه في السودان والمكاتب
التمثيليه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ولعائلاتهم من مواطني روسيا وبلدان رابطه
الدول المستقله وايضا عدد من الدول
الصديقه
المزيد معنا من مدينه بورتسودان مراسل
العربيه نزار البقد نزار انقل لنا المشهد
من عندك تفضل نزار
مشهد كالتالي هو
بعمليات السفر والمغادره من هذا الميناء
من خلف مباشره الى بورسودان حتى الان عبر
المطار الرئيس في هذه المدينه بولايه
البحر الاحمر حتى يوم الامس اكثر من 70
رحله جويه لطائرات مختلفه هبطت في مطار
بورسودان واقلت اكثر من
6500 من الراغبين في مغادره السودان
والراغبين في اجلائهم من مختلف الدول
العربيه والاسيويه والاوروبيه والاجنبيه
غادروا خلال الايام الماضيه عبر مطار
بورسودان في نحو 70 رحله جويه اما على
صعيد مينا بورسودان اكثر من 25 رحله بحريه
السفن وقطع بحريه وحربيه وصلت خلال الايام
الماضيه الى ميناء بورسودان واقلت اكثر من
عشره الاف من طالبي الاجلاء والراغبين في
مغادره السودان جراء الاحداث والاشتباكات
والمواجهات المسلحه التي اندلعت قبل اكثر
من اسبوعين في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
عدد من مدن السودان العمليات مستمره
اللجان المعنيه بعمليه ترتيب اوضاع
المغادرين تعمل بتنسيق تام هذه العمليه
التي يشرف عليها اشرافا كاملا الجيش
السوداني قياده منطقه البحر الاحمر
العسكريه ايضا ترتب هذا الامر بتنسيق مع
هيئه الموانئ البحريه التي ايضا تعمل
بتنسيق وبترتيب مع كل الوحدات والجهات
الامنيه التي تنسق هذه العمليه
في واحده من الاشارات المهمه التي بس
سؤال في بعمليه التنسيق والتامين هل من
ارقام ولائحه موجوده اصلا ام انه التحرك
بالنسبه ان كان للسفن او حتى الطائرات لمن
قدم وللاولويه لمن جاء
هذه العمليه تتم على مستويين مستوى المطار
في مدينه بورسودان ومستوى الميناء هنا من
خلف هذا الامر يتم بتنسيق عبر لجنتين لجنه
اولى معنيه بسفر ومغادره رعايه الدول
وممثلي البعثات الدبلوماسيه عبر الميناء
ولجنه اخرى ايضا معنيه بترتيب وتنسيق سفر
رعايه الدول وممثلي الدول الاجنبيه هنا في
السودان عبر المطار ممثلي او البعثات
الدبلوماسيه او وزارات الخارجيه في عدد من
الدول تنسق مع اللجنه المعنيه هنا في
ولايه البحر الاحمر يتم الدفع بقوائم
المسافرين يتم تحديد السفريات سواء كان
عبر البحر او عبر الميناء وبعده مباشره
يتم التواصل مع الراغبين في الاجلاء وصولا
الى مدينه هكذا تتم هذه العمليه بتنسيق
وبترتيب هنالك قوائم تاتي تباعا هنالك
برقيات هنالك طلبيات تصل الى هيئه الموانئ
تصل الى اللجنه المعنيه تصل الى مطار
بورسودان
عبر ادارته التي تعمل على مدار الساعه
تؤمن وصول الطائرات تعطي الاذن لهبوط
الطائرات الحربيه وعدد من الطائرات التي
تصل كما ذكرنا الى مطار وبعدها بطبيعه
الحال يتم اخطار الراغبين في المغادره كنت
اريد ان اشير في في عجاله الى الجهد
الشعبي المبذول الان هنا في ولايه البحر
الاحمر من جمعيات طوعيه من منظمات
الشبابيه هذه المنظمات تعمل ليله نهار على
ترتيب اوضاع المسافرين تقديم الدعم الفني
تقديم الطعام تقديم الغذاء تقديم الماوى
لالاف من السوريين ومن اليمنيين ومن طالبي
السفر عبر ميناء حتى من الاشارات
المجتمعيه هنا بان عدد من سائقي سيارات
الاجره وما تعرفون بالركشه لا يتلقون
المال اطلاقا ممن يركبون او يتجولون او
يذهبون الى سوق بورسودان باعتبار انهم في
الظروف انسانيه تستدعي الوقوف هذه احدى
اللم حات التكافليه والتضامنيه لمواطني
مدينه بورسودان الذين يقولون بانهم على
قلب رجل واحد مع كل الذين عانوا من هذه
الازمه سواء كان من السودانيين او من
رعايه الدول الاجنبيه الذين وصلوا الى
مدينه بورسودان في شرق السودان من مدينه
شكرا جزيلا لك
ومن الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد
اسحاق عثمان اهلا بك استاذ محمد باخر
المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول التطورات
الميدانيه
مرحبا
بحري او في الخرطوم بحري في هذه المنطقه
بالتحديد لازال
الجديد في الامر انتشار بعض
العقول اراها تعمل على تنشيط هذه
المنطقه تعلمين بان هذه المنطقه جسر
الحلفايه شهدت معارك دراما طيله ايام
الفائده الان ظهرت بعض القوات الجيش تعمل
لتنشيط هذه الاحياء هذه الاحياء المجاوره
لمنطقه جسر الماء الحلفايه
استاذ محمد عمليات التمشيط منذ ان حدثت
تلك الاشتباكات ام انه هناك تحركات على
الارض
تخيف الجيش ليقوم بعمليات التمشيط مجددا
معلوم بان
شهيده مناطق بحري تدخل كبير لسلاح الجو
هو محاوله عبور جسر جسر حلفايه كما حدث
منذ يومين تقريبا
في القادم تجدهم
يستخدمون او يمشون على ارجلهم يخطبون في
المباني المهجوره تجدهم في
الولايات تحت التشييد هم يحاولون ان ينجوا
الوضع الان هذه الب
دايات عنها غالبا ما تكون هي
لا توجد فيها سكان هي غير مكتمله لذلك هي
بالنسبه لهم تمثل حصا امينا ولكن احيانا
احيانا بعض السكان هؤلاء او هذه المناطق
هذه الاحياء يبلغون عنهم يتعرضون لهم تحصل
بعض المناوشات بينهم وبين سكان هذه
الاحياء خصوصا في فترات النهار في فترات
المساء والليل يخطبون لا يمكن لا رصدهم
ولكن في فترات النهار يقولون بصوره واضحه
مما يجعل بعض سكان الاحياء يتعاملون
مباشره مع هذه القوات التي تبشق المنطقه
يبلغنا عنهم بصوره مباشره هل من ضحايا وهل
من امكانيه لوصول سيارات الاسعاف والتواقم
الطبيه الى تلك المناطق او لا
حديث بالصوره مباشره
ولكن لاحظنا عدم التنقل سيارات الاسعاف في
كل الاحداث من الوصول لان هناك اشكاليات
وعدم الالتزام عند الاطراف
فتح المسارات الانسانيه بالاسعافات لسحب
هؤلاء المصابين ربما تتعرض هذه الاسعافات
نفسها
للقصف او ربما تتعرض كذلك بعض القناصين
الذين يوجدون في اعلى البنايات الاستهداف
من الخرطوم بحري كان معنا الصحفي محمد
اسحاق عثمان شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات
وفي متابعه لتطورات الاوضاع الصحيه قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن قال ان 39 مشفا خرجت
عن الخدمه وذلك منذ بدء الاشتباكات مؤكدا
للعربيه ان قوات الدعم السريعه حولت بعض
المستشفيات التي تقنات عسكريه عبد الرحمن
دعا الى فتح ممرات انسانيه لاغاثه الضحايا
مسلسلات التي توقفت على الخدمه منذ صباح
يوم 15 وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه
المستشفيات هي في مناطق الاشتباكات حتى
تاريخ اليوم مناطق غير امنه هي المستشفيات
التي متاخمه لمناطق الاشتباك شارع القصر
وشارع
المطار
والقياده والاذاعه ومركز
ومركز البحري
وقال سكرتير نقابه اطباء السودان عطيه عبد
الله للعربيه ان كل المستشفيات العامه في
الخرطوم توقفت عن العمل بسبب عدم توفره
الوقود مشددا ان الحل الوحيد للوضع
الانساني هو وقف القتال حيث وصف الاوضاع
الصحيه بالكارثيه
الاوضاع في الجنينه كارثيه للغايه نعم
النظام الصحي لازال يتهاوى في كل لحظه
وحين بالامس عدد من المستشفيات خرجت خارج
الخدمه لانه لم نستطيع ايصال كوادر طبيه
اليها وبعض الاخر خرج من الخدمه لانقطاع
الوقود الجازلين وايضا هنالك يعني عدد من
الولايات تعاني من نقص في الاكسجين حتى في
ولايه الخرطوم
هذه العوامل مجتمعه وهو ما ظللنا نحذر منه
من اليوم الاول ستؤدي الى الى نتيجه لا
نتمناها ابدا وهي انهيار النظام الصحيه
نحن تخوف ان يحدث مع يعني يحصل ما حدث
الجنينه في عدد من المدن وهو ما تخوف عنه
لذلك نحن مطالبتنا لطرفي الصراع الان هي
ايقاف هذه الحرب داخل ولايه الخرطوم هنالك
مستشفيات توقفت تماما لانه ما فيها معينات
طبيه
هذا ومع استمرار المواجهات بات النزوح
والحل امام الالاف من السودانيين طبعا
هربا من الاقتتال الدائر وفي هذه الاثناء
كشفت بيانات المنظمه الدوليه للهجره الى
نزوح اكثر من
334 الف شخص داخل السودان منذ بدء
الاشتباكات فيما افاد مسؤول بالامم
المتحده بعبور اكثر من 100 الف شخص حدود
السوداني الى دول مجاوره حتى الان مؤكدا
ان الامم المتحده بحاجه لواحد فاصله خمسه
مليار دولار لتلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه
في السودان لهذا العام
من جانبه قرر الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريوس ارساله منسقه الاغاثه في
حالات الطوارئ وكيل الامين العام لشؤون
الانسانيه مارتن جرافيس الى السودان
لاستكشاف سبل تقديم الاغاثه الفوريه
لملايين الاشخاص الذين انقلبت حياتهم راسا
على عقب بسبب القتال الدائر في السودان
وقد اظهرت صور نزوح عشرات الالاف من
الاشخاص عبر نيالا عاصمه جنوبي دارفور
طبعا مع استمرار المواجهات متابعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سوريا واليمن ودول اخرى
هذا وتستمر موجات النزوح من السودان الى
مصر حيث اظهرت صور جديده نزوح المئات من
السودانيين عبر منطقه وادي حلفا اظهرت
الصور ازدحاما شديدا بين النازحين الذين
ينتقلون الى المناطق الامنه بعيدا عن
ساحات الصراع عبر شاحنات مكتظه تحمل
النساء والاطفال والرجال وسط درجات حراره
مرتفعه تزيد المعاناه بالنسبه للفارين
من الخرطوم كانت جارنا عربيه ب 2 مليار
وما في الولوج عشان احنا نطفى بالمبلغ ده
[موسيقى]
ولمده دولار عندنا ذهب وركبنا لحد ما
وصلنا طلعنا من الجوف التوتر والضرب لحد
ما حصلنا
حلفا وجينا مع العلاج عشان نمشيو في في
يعني الودي جيد في
العربات
وفي محاوله لحلحله الازمه الراهنه التقى
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري بالقاهره
مع السفير دفع الله الحاج علي المبعوث
الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان جرى خلال اللقاء بحث
الازمه السودانيه والصراع المستمر منذ 18
يوما
قبل ذلك اقترح رئيس الوزراء السوداني
السابق عبد الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لتوفير الاساسي
لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى
الاتفاق على انشاء ممرات انسانيه دائمه
حمدوك اقترح ايضا اشراك المدنيين
السودانيين في مفاوضات شامله واستئناف
العمليه السياسيه مؤكدا ان استمرار الحرب
في السودان وانتشارها في رقعه اوسع قد يضر
العالم باسره
وفي كلمته امام المندوبين الدائمين في
الجامعه العربيه الذي الذين عقدوا اجتماعا
في القاهره لبحث الاوضاع في السودان جدد
فهد الخم علي وهو نائب المندوب الدائم
للسعوديه لدى الجامعه العربيه دعوه بلاده
لايقاف المواجهات في السودان للحفاظ على
حياه المدنيين
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تجدد دعوتها لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه
والتحلي باقصى درجات ضبط النفس وتجنب
التصعيد وتقريب مصلحه الشعب السوداني
للحفاظ على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده الى
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يهدف الى الوصول
الى اعلان سياسي يحقق الامن والاستقرار
للسودان وشعبه الشقيق
وتؤكد المملكه على اهميه الالتزام بالهدنه
القائمه وحمايه المدنيين والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه وتوفير الممرات الامنه
للعاملين في المجال الانساني كما تؤكد
المملكه على ضروره العمل على تيسير وتامين
عمليات الاجلاء للمدنيين
وفي هذا السياق قال محمد مصطفى عرفي وهو
مندوب مصر الدائم لدى الجامعه العربيه
قال واكد على ضروره وقف اطلاق النار فورا
في السودان
اننا نؤكد من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس على
ضروره الوقف الفوري غير المشروط للعنف
واتاحه الفرصه كامله لانجاح جهود التسويه
وجعلها تؤتي ثمارها في القريب العاجل
ونحذر من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس من ان
المساس بالمدنيين بالسودان واستهداف
منشاتهم لا سيما الطيبيه منها هو امر خطير
للغايه ويمثل انتهاكا واضحا وسافرا
للقانون الدولي والقانون الدولي الانساني
على كل المزيد معنا من عمان عمار عمار
المدير الاقليمي للاعلام والمناصره في
اليونيسف لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا اهلا بك استاذ عمار اسمح لي ان
ابدا بما تناقلته الارقام الرسميه من
نقابه الاطباء في السودان تتحدث عن
447 قتيلا في المجمل منذ بدء الاشتباكات
اضافه الى
2255 مصاب حتى الان هل نعلم عدد الاطفال
من بينهم كم هو
شكرا على الاستضافه للاسف الشديد عدد
الضحايا كتير كبير خاصه بين المدنيين وعدد
الاطفال الاسبوع الماضي تقريبا بعد القتال
بكم يوم كان عن تسع اطفال مؤكدين وخمسه
وخمسين طفل جريح لكن هناك صعوبه في في
التحقق من الارقام والاصابات بين الاطفال
بسبب القتال الدائر لكن نحن نعلم ان للاسف
ان الرقم بين الاطفال اكبر من هيك بكثير
وخاصه مع استمرار القتال هيكون في مزيد
بين الضحايا من الضحايا بين الاطفال طب
خبرنا سيد عمار عن عملكم على الارض كيف هو
بالسودان وتقييمكم للوضع الان
يعني الوضع الانساني اذا طقمنا للوضع
الانساني كارثي للاسف خاصه على الاطفال مع
يعني اكثر من اسبوعين على القتال يضع
الاطفال في وضع كتير صعب من الناحيه
النفسيه وايضا من الناحيه ايضا بحاجه الى
الى الماكل المشطب الرعايه الحمايه الطفل
راينا المدارس ما زالت مغلقه منذ اكثر من
اسبوعين وهذا طبعا بضع الاطفال في
الانتهاكات جسيمه مثل التجنيد القصبي بين
الجماعات المسلحه
الانتهاكات الجسديه الانتهاكات النفسيه
التي المدارس يعني تقوم في في مثل هذه
الاوقات الحرجه بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
راينا انه في 50 الف يعني عندنا خمسين الف
طفل بعاني من سوء التغذيه الحاد الوخيه من
قطعت عنهم العلاج في مراكز او الرعايه
المنقذه للحياه في المراكز التغذيه
التابعه التي تدعمها في خاصه في مناطق
الاشتباكات وهذول حياتهم في قطر داهم اذا
اذا ما استمرت الاشتباكات
هل لكم تحرك على الارض سيد عمار نعم
تحركنا على الارض نحن قمنا بتقديم مساعدات
طبيه عاجله الى العديد من المستشفيات في
الخرطوم كذلك الى عدد الى المستشفيات في
شمال دارفور بالاضافه الى توفير المياه
ايضا لبعض المستشفيات في شمال دارفور
تقديم المساعدات في بعض المناطق التي نجح
اليها
العائلات والاطفال لكن تبقى هذه المساعدات
قليله مقارنه بالاحتياجات الانسانيه
الهائله الموجوده على الارض
بيحتاج بشكل ماء مباشر انه يكون في وقف
قتال يكون في هدم انسانيه لحتى نقدر انه
نوصل للاطفال ونساعدهم لانه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه هائله واي وقت
بنتاخرى الاطفال وحياتهم في خطر داهم هذا
بالشكل الاول بالمصاف الاول بالتاني يكون
في هدنه انسانيه مثبته لحتى يقدروا
الاشخاص والاطفال انه اللي بدي اياها
يروحوا على اماكن اكثر امنا يستطيعوا ان
يقوموا بذلك الذين بحاجه لرعايه طبيه
يصلوا الى المستشفيات بالاضافه الى ذلك
العائلات التي بحاجه ان تتزود بالماكل
والمشرب والتعامل والادويه التي كان من
الصعب ان تكون بها خلال الايام الماضيه
وما زال بسبب
الشبكات المستمره ان تقوم بذلك لكن
الشيء الاساسي التي يجب ان يقوم به ان
يكون في وقف قتال لانه اطفال السودان هم
عم يدفعوا الثمن للاسف الشديد في هذه
الاوقات وعندما تتحدث عن الهدن هل تطبيقها
وان كانت قد خلقت اكثر من مره وفي اكثر من
منطقه ساعدتكم على التحرك اكثر او لا
لم تساعد على التحرك لانه بالهودنا يجب ان
يتم تصبيرها بشكل كامل ويجب ان تكون
مكرونه ايضا بضمانات امنيه
للمنظمات الانسانيه العامله على ارض
الميدان فهذول الشرطين اساسيين لحتى تقدر
منظمات انسانيه اخرى ان تقوم بشكل فعال
وشامل وكامل للاستجابه الانسانيه الهائله
على ارض على ارض الميدان وخاصه في المناطق
التي تشهد اشتباكاتهم الشرطين اليونيسف
عندها طبعا من اكثر من 70 عاما في البلد
عندها كان برامج موجوده لديها الامكانيات
حتى تقوم باستجابه سريعه وشامله عندنا
الفرق التي تعمل ايضا في اماكن مختلفه في
السودان منها بورسودان لحتى ايضا رفع
الجهازيه الكامله متى تحققت هذه الشروط
لحتى يكون في استجابه قصوى فهنا يجب ان
تكون التركيز في في الان وفي الايام
القادمه انه كيفيه تثبيت الهدنه الانسانيه
لحتى نقدر نساعد الاطفال او متضررين بعض
المنظمات اوقفت عملها واجلت موظفيها
اليونيسف بعيده كل البعد عن مثل هذه
الخطوه
الموظفين غير الاصليين ايضا من مناطق
الاشتباكات لتقليل لحده المخاطر التي يمكن
ان تقع عليهم لكن ما زال لدينا فرق موجوده
مثلا في بورسودان تقوم بالعمل ايضا
العمليات الانسانيه برفع الجهوديه
بالاضافه الى ذلك لدينا ايضا برامج ما
زالت مستمره في المناطق اخرى من السودان
من ضمنها برامج التغذيه للاطفال الذين
يعانون من سوء التغذيه الحاد والبخيم
وايضا مثل هذه البرامج لكن التركيز الاول
في هذه الاوقات الحرجه يجب ان يكون
للاستجابه للاحتياجات الانسانيه الطارئه
فيما يتعلق بوضع الاطفال الحرج في المناطق
التي تشهد اشتباكات هو التركيز على
الامهات ايضا اليس كذلك سيد عمار بطبيعه
الحال وخاصه الامهات الذين
هم عندهم اطفال المرضعات
النساء الحوامل لانه هدول طبعا بيكون
وضعهم خطر لا يجب ان تقدم لهم رعايه صحيه
خاصه خاصه في هذه الاوقات في انقطاع مثلا
حكينا عن موضوع المستشفيات انه العديد من
المستشفيات تدمرت او تضررت او اصبحت خارج
الخدمه تمام فهذا بالمقام الاول ثانيا
العديد من النساء الحوامل والمرضعات
والاطفال الصغار ما زالوا عالقين في مناطق
الاشتباكات بالطبع فهكذا وضع بزيت الخطر
كثير كبير على حياته خاصه بوجود شخص في
المواد الغذائيه او عدم الامكانيه ايضا
للناس الموجودين في المناطق الاشتباكات ان
يحصلوا على المواد الغذائيه وايضا هناك
شخص في الاموال وارتفاع الاسعار الغذائيه
التي كلها هذه العوامل بيكون عائق او بشكل
خطر اضافي على سوق التغذيه بالنسبه
للامهات للامهات وايضا بالنسبه للاطفال في
هذه الاوقات مخزون اليونيسف في السودان هل
هو كافن بمعنى انه بحال تم الاعلان عن
العوده لاطلاق المشاريع التي كانت قائمه
اليونسف قادره على تفعيلها مباشره لماذا
بتعمل
لحتى يكون في استجابه شامله لكن هون في
نقطه كتير مهمه انه اليونيسف ومنظمات
انسانيه اخرى تعرضت ايضا مكاتبها
ومؤسساتها
والمخازنها
للنهب من قبل افراد مسلحين ومن ضمنها ايضا
فيما يتعلق مواد غذائيه وغير غذائيه
بالاضافه الى المواد الخاصه بالتغذيه
للاطفال الذين يعانون من سوء التغذيه
وايضا
التحصين يعني الباكسينيشن ايضا تم ايضا في
عدد كبير منها تدمر بسبب عمليات النهب
التي حصلت وما زالت مستمره خلال الايام
القادمه وهذا بحد من قدره ان ينصف الاسد
في الشديد انه يكون في استجابه كثير كثير
سريعه في في الايام القادمه متى تم الظروف
بذلك وبيضع خطر وهذه العمليات النهب للاسف
تضع حياه الاطفال في خطر ونحن من اشدتنا
انه يجب حمايه المنظمات الدوليه من ضمنها
وايضا المواد التي تعود اليها حتى تكون
استجابتها كتير سريعه لكن نحن برجع باكد
لك انه نحن استجبتنا حتكون سريعه وشامله
متى تحققت الظروف للقيام بذلك مع انه في
الوقت الحالي عم تقدم المساعدات لكن ليس
وفقا للاحتياجات الانسانيه الهائله لانه
يجب ان يكون هناك ضمانات امنيه شامله
وكامله لحتى نقدر نوصل لجميع المناطق
المتضرره هلا تحدثت عن نهب
مخازن ان كانت تابعه لليونيسف ولغيرها من
المنظمات ولكن هل لديكم جرد لحجم الخسائر
بالنسبه لليونيسف او لا
هناك للاسف الشديد
يعني العديد من
المواد المنقذه للحياه فقدت يعني اضطرينا
انه الى خساره اكثر من مليون لقاح ضد شلل
الاطفال في في في بعض المناطق التي نعمل
بها وفي دارفور ايضا بسبب الذي تعرضت اليه
يعني مخزننا ومخازن الشركاء ايضا فيما
يتعلق بسلسله التوريد يعني سلسله التبريد
انه ايضا السودان كانت بتعاني ما قبل
الازمه في في هبوط في مؤشر ايضا التطعيم
التطعيم فيما يتعلق للاطفال اللقاحات
المنقذه للحياه كان في نزول 6% مع فقدان
هذه اللقاحات واستمرار ايضا النائب المواد
المنقذه للحياه للاطفال بضع يعني طبعا
اليونيسف والاطفال في وضع خطر اكبر
فبالتالي بنرجع بنقول نقوم بجرزه كامله
لكن الخسائر كبيره لكن ما زلنا موجودين ما
زال عندنا الامكانيات انه برد فعل سريع ما
تتوفرت الظروف لكن مناشدتنا في هذه الظروف
الصعبه طبعا الحمايه طبعا بالمقام الاول
المدنيين والاطفال من اتبعات القتال حمايه
ايضا
الخدمات الاساسيه التي يعتمد عليها
الاطفال للحياه مثل مثل
صالحه للشرب المستشفيات والمراكز العلاجيه
التي تقدم الحياه
الخدمات المنقذه للحياه للاطفال الذين
يعانون من سوره التغذيه وايضا السماح
للاطفال وعائلاتهم الذين يرغبون في الرحيل
الى اماكن اكثر امنا بالقيام بذلك لكن
بشكل اساسي ايضا وموازي يجب حمايه ايضا
المواد المنقذه للحياه التي موجوده عند
المنظمات الدوليه من ضمنها اليونيسف لحتى
يعني تكون اذا توفرت الظروف نقوم برد فعل
سريع لمساعدتهم اذا استمر ما هو الوضع
عليه حاليا بيضع خياط الاطفال في خطر
متزايد وايضا قدره المنظمه الدوليه على
الاستجابه بكون اقل في الفترات القادمه
المخ بالنسبه لصحه الاطفال في غياب
التلقيح او عمليات التلقيح في كثير من
المناطق اكثر ما يخيفكم بهذا الاطار وهل
من مخاوف من اوئه معينه نعم يعني كان في
الاوبئه الموجوده على سبيل المثال
الكوليرا الميزه كانت موجوده ما قبل
النزاع وكان هناك 11 مليون شخص بحاجه الى
خدمات الوصول الى اعدادات المياه الصالحه
للشرب الى خدمات الصف الصحي وبالتالي مع
القتال
الدائره الان ما زالت هذه الاحتياجات
موجوده ولكن تضاعفت ومن ضمنها ايضا الوصول
الى المياه الصالحه للشربه للاشخاص
الموجودين في مناطق القتال او الاشخاص في
المناطق الاخرى الذين لا اصلا لم تتوافر
لديهم المياه الصالحه للشرب سيضطر الى شرب
مياه غير صالحه وهذا بعرضهم ايضا الى
مشاكل صحيه وايضا الى تفاقم مشكله الامراض
المنقوله بالمياه مثل البوليرا والامراض
الاخرى فممكن يكون امام ايضا امراض وبائيه
بتضع الاطفال في في المقام الاول بشكل خطر
فهذا ايضا جانب اخر يجب الالتفات اليه
ممكن يكون على شكل عمل خطر على على
الاطفال لا شك بانكم تتواصلون مع الجهات
المتصارعه لتامين موظفيكم وامين
حركاتكم وتنقلكم هل من تجاوب
طبعا يعني بالنسبه لالنا
مثل ما حكينا اللي كان في النقل لبعض
الموظفين الى اماكن اخرى
لحتى مخفف
المخاطر عليهم كمان ايضا هناك عدد من
الموظفين ايضا
تم نقرهم الى خارج البلاد لكن هناك موظفين
الان نعمل من مناطق اذا بدك امنه لحتى
نقدر نقوم في البرمجه ومتابعه عملياتها
الانسانيه لكن نحن طلبنا الى الجميع
الاطراف المتحاربه انه الوضع الانساني
للاطفال كان كثير صعب اكثر من سبعه ثمانيه
فاصله خمسه مليون طفل قبل الازمه كانوا
بحاجه
مليون طفل خارج المدارس وهناك 3 مليون طفل
بعاني من سوء التغذيه فكانت الاحتياجات
الانسانيه القتال الموجود الان ما زالت
اكثر في خطر دائم على حياتهم فبنطلب من
جميع الاطراف انه يكون في هدنه انسانيه
نقدر بالفعل الاطفال
الاخرين ونقوم بتقديم الخدمات المن حياتهم
وايضا السماح لهم ايضا في في
ارادوا ذلك ان يقوموا بالخروج الى مناطق
اخرى اكثر امنا لكن هو السلام يعني الحل
الوحيد للاطفال يعني ما في
انسانيه ما قبل هائله قبل النزاع تبعات
انسانيه هائله الان مع النجاح وبالتالي
اذا ننظر ننظر الى المستقبل وضع الاطفال
في السودان يعني في قطر الدائم من عمان
عمار عمار المدير الاقليمي للاعلام
والمناصره في اليونيسف لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا شكرا جزيلا لك
لازم اشتغل يعني في في الظروف
السلع في زياده اي حاجه زايده لازم انا
اشتغل
بجيب اشتغل لي زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه
البلد ما امنا
صعب
طبعا ما بيعرف
لازم واحد تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يشتغل القواد
مع بابا والقمع منه فايده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات